Dwight Kurt Schrute has shown himself to be,
at various points, both terribly misguided and
an unexpected voice of reason on "The Office."
More often than you might expect, the eccentric
beet farmer and assistant to the regional manager
played by Rainn Wilson on the classic NBC
sitcom is actually worth listening to.
Despite his strangeness, Dwight often
shows a knack for problem-solving
and critical thinking that proves
indispensable in the workplace.
At one point, he brings his spud gun into
work in a duffel bag, just to test the office
park's security. Who else would take that
initiative? Plus, he's all about loyalty.
"But, if there were somewhere else
that valued that loyalty more highly,
I'm going wherever they value loyalty the most."
Don't think about that one too hard.
By all accounts - particularly his own - Dwight
is a force to be reckoned with and an asset to
be paid attention to. But the people around Dwight
don't regard him this way very often — or at all,
really. Dwight isn't actually treated fairly
in most instances. His boss and idol Michael
Scott repeatedly spurns him, both in terms of
friendship and the promotions Dwight craves.
Consider Michael's Rolodex entry on
Dwight, which reads simply, quote:
"Tall. Beets." Might Dwight, the resident weirdo
of "The Office," be its underappreciated hero?
There are many signs that point to
this being true, but something that
happens during "The Office" Season 2 really
drives this point home. Here's the "Office"
conflict that has fans reevaluating
[RE-aval-u-a-ting] Dwight - and Jim.
Of course, nobody wants to dislike the
big hero Jim. And it is entertaining
to watch Dwight swing wildly
between oblivious incompetence,
frustration, and genuine dominance where
he uses his intelligence to command a
situation and the people in it. Over time,
however, it's hard not to notice how often
Dwight is met with dismissiveness and even
full-on antagonism no matter how he behaves.
That's not to say he doesn't
sometimes instigate problems himself.
The incessant prank war between Dwight
and Jim Halpert, the time Dwight put the
entire office in real danger to prove a point
about being prepared in the event of a fire,
the verbal jabs he throws at his fellow Dunder
Mifflin employees — that's just the tip of the
iceberg. But the issue is that Dwight isn't always
to blame, and when he feels uncomfortable at work
and turns to his company for help, he is,
at best, laughed at. At worst, he's ignored.
One of the worst examples of the lack
of respect Dwight gets comes from human
resources representative Toby Flenderson in
the Season 2 episode "Conflict Resolution."
The episode sees Dwight approaching Toby with
some very legitimate claims about Jim's behavior.
It's Toby's job to hear Dwight out,
address his concerns appropriately,
and resolve the conflict between Dwight
and Jim. Unfortunately, Toby neglects him,
sticking all of Dwight's complaints in
a box rather than taking them seriously.
"The Office" is a comedy, of course, but if
we're thinking in terms of real-life companies,
Toby's actions are almost
certainly a violation of procedure,
and outside of a professional
context, it's just a jerk move.
As many fans have pointed out, Toby kind
of lets everyone down in the episode,
as it reveals that he's kept a massive file
of unresolved complaints from Dunder Mifflin
employees held back. But it's particularly hard
on Dwight, who's clearly complained about Jim
for years and been ignored basically every time.
Sure, Dwight's a lot to handle on his own, but if
an employee is that concerned about a coworker,
ignoring it probably isn't the best response.
Dwight is visibly distressed by Jim's actions.
He doesn't find Jim's antics funny, and the
show doesn't depict their prank war as harmless
fun between friends. Jim's behavior messes with
Dwight's sense of his own sanity, his emotions,
and his ability to do his job. At one point,
Jim even tricks him into going into the
women's restroom. This adds up to a textbook
hostile work environment, but Toby never lifts
a finger to do what he is literally paid to do.
Fans of "The Office" are now looking back on
the episode and feeling sympathy for Dwight,
seeing him as a complicated character
who deserved some kindness here.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.